what's happening there reject nation
we're gonna watch
superman and lois with greg and john
today hey now
so if you guys can go ahead and hit that
like button to show your support for
superman and lois
that'd be great because this show is
awesome and more people need to hop on
the train
subscribe click that notification bell
to get notified you know how those work
also full length watch alongs where you
sync up with the time code where are
they john
they are over at our patreon page.com
real the real rejects there you go and
over there
we have full-length watch-alongs
reaction highlights for
many shows we're at this and they're all
the same tier we've said
this all smoother before and uh big
thanks super thumb jindal
or his co-editor for whichever one
for editing this highlights for us keep
trying to make us look good
because we're not succeeding we're not
helping you at all let's watch this
what episode is this seven six seven
i forget when episode number episode no
i don't know
let's just do it yeah
couples counseling synthesis therapy
it's a therapy right
crossover we have been having some
life changes but today i kind of got
blindsided and i lost my temper
and i am worried that if i can't pull it
together i'm at risk of hurting someone
i really love
more than i already have
seems like it's gonna be a very lowest
focus episode my last time in a high
school locker room
probably ever dad uh no i'm good uh can
you just hold this
yes you're left out man
don't forget it he doesn't need your
puny human tools
i'll be in the barn you two stay out of
trouble
mom you think maybe i could come with
you
i know i feel like i wasn't much help
fixing the truck but i i think i can
help you
yeah sure okay identify
yourself lois lane voice authentication
confirmed
good morning lois oh that's right she
doesn't know yet
how can i help you miss lane um what can
you tell me about john henry irons
cool whoa that was easy
super easy barely an inconvenience
ranger two tours in afghanistan
the problem is john irons died six years
ago
under mysterious circumstances at least
that's what happened to the john irons
of this earth
how did you get here
through a very cool transition
i call it i was like [ __ ] i don't want
to go
i want to go to another universe i just
destroyed this universe
you have no idea how much i care about
these people i do know
what happened on my world is already
happening on this one the kryptonians
are here
and you joining them is the last i'll
know to fall before it all goes to hell
so on his earth are there like are there
other versions of
people from here yeah sometimes
like you
[Music]
lois you're the one who killed them
what are you talking about she was
everything to me oh
man she was the love of my
life oh awkward
the mother of my daughter
until you murdered her and i won't let
you do it again
just one f-bomb come on cw
give it to us i think one f-bomb is
required
we'll figure this out we've been in
similar situations learning that the man
who's trying to kill your husband is
your other husband from another world
i mean other than the suit this guy was
just like me right up until he started
killing innocent people
i feel sorry for him but that was his
life on his earth
he's here now and we need answers
we need him to tell us how to save our
world
hmm
i love you lois i love you too
lois has to sleep with him they gotta
become a polygamous
trio yeah let's just
let's take a break from the rv i'll let
you know before i want to go back in
but then wants to do something go do
something normal john
step sister get to meet you
seem really cool oh no he's gonna want
to be
he's gonna call john henry irons daddy
no
our humanity oh
boy oh boy
no
[Music]
one f-bomb come on
you know they want to say it
damn
yep looks like jonathan's found a new
dead
intruder uh you're not accepted here
either required
uh uh okay okay uh jonathan ken john
john kent
you are not authorized oh no
oh
[Music]
hurry
oh my god
oh my god that was intense oh
no there was a risk i know you did and
yet you went in
anyway alone behind my back you
almost died because you
only person that would have been to
blame is yourself
get out of my face
a therapy i think what you really meant
to say you were scared you reckon he was
gonna die are you okay i'm fine
but it is okay to ask for help and i
want to be that person for you always
but
i also understand if i'm not right now
what about the woman you talked to
before
your dad's friend like just think about
it god you know if
not many men can ask their significant
others to
go to therapy in such a classy way
lois you're heard of betterhelp.com
you can't trust him sam you're wrong
what if there were more kryptonians
and he decided he was loyal to them he
would choose his guide
over mankind you and i should talk are
you gonna be evil
you gotta tell me if you are i need to
prepare for that
honestly it's a miracle he's alive
sounds like
whatever happened it scared you
you have no idea
sounds like you felt helpless powerless
not like i have in a long time probably
not
since you're miscarriage
miscarriages are pretty common common
yes but they can also be traumatic
and as i recall you already had a name
picked out
we were gonna name her after my
grandmother
natalie lieutenant trask here's an idea
natalie huh leave me and my friend here
alone for 10 minutes
negative he's going back to a cell
general lane's orders
know your prom rosetti you're a stickler
for the rules
you know your problem nothing
your problems are over
whoa whoa oh you're diarrhea's like what
the hell
are you your problems are just getting
started
oh that's it nothing else
what else do you want me to say that he
was only there because of me and that if
he had gotten hurt or worse it would
have been because of me i can't
but you have to realize this is this the
part where you tell me the miscarriage
wasn't my fault because
your miscarriage wasn't because of
something you did
or didn't do it was something that
happened to you
i was so excited to meet her
i wish there was a shortcut but you have
to
allow yourself to go through the
grieving process
they had a family a child a daughter
named natalie
after my mother okay yep that's that
matt
same name is the baby you lost yep yeah
thank you
last time on superman hello sir it's
trask
he's dead sir get me eyes i'm rossetti
i'll find him
wait sector five you can't he's in the
kryptonite bullet chamber
stockpile of kryptonite it's a research
and development lab
about a dozen prototypes for kryptonite
based weapon
fragment grenades bladed weapons but
nothing about you man
it's got nothing to do with you i
promise there's a chance you don't come
back alive
yeah to hell with you man
we'll talk about this later laser my way
through this whole fight
talk to me general i'm lying down here
it's number seven seven
three four
seven seven three four only one there
welcome to hell
where's irons whatever he's got planned
i can help you you've got it all wrong
the only person who needs help is you
oh oh [ __ ]
oh boy
step up irons
go
damn it it just stinks
what's going on
just shove it in his mouth
you're lucky i have a mission to
complete
oh god damn
oh kryptonite spear
all the bvs weapons yeah
i'm not your enemy i figure
why take the cheeks drop the weapon now
[Music]
wanted to see me here i am you should go
lois
i'm not going anywhere suit yourself god
i know about natalie
please i see the anger in your eyes it's
covering something i can relate to
and it's not your fault but it's not his
fault either
our superman is good
looks like you guys did need lois
[Music]
daddy dad
[Laughter]
when you and your brother were about 18
months old i got pregnant
i ended up losing the baby so it's
really not something
that i talk about much
all this time i thought i was okay
and then i'm just being reminded of the
child that i lost
and then almost losing you i lost it
and i said some things i never should
have said and that i didn't mean
oh that's no excuse and i never should
have yelled at you like that
and i'm so sorry and i love you so much
and i hope you forgive me
i know what it's like to be in the orbit
of someone who can juggle semi trucks
we are the extraordinary humans in a
family of super people
oh and we have to stick together
hell yeah you [ __ ] matter
throw that f-bomb
yeah and i'm free to just drive out of
here
if there really is a war coming we're
gonna need all the help we can get
this is a show of trust i'll let you
live doesn't mean i'm ready to fight by
your side
i understand if you change your mind you
know how to find me miss lane
i hope he finds some solace there's a
lot i want to say
but you're not the woman i want to say
it to you just looked like her
welcome back captain nuzzle erase the
profile
for captain luther start a new one for
me john henry irons
how about you shut down i think i'll
just drive for a while as you wish
john
doe beautiful hey plus
good show i thought that was a very uh
fantastic
a wonderfully emotional episode um
i think i don't know that's the first
thing that comes to my mind is just
this is like another caliber for this
show in terms of
the drama the family stakes you know
it's already been pretty well locked
into that stuff and then this episode
made me cry like left and right
um and so it's a real testament to just
the amount of character building that
they've been able to do over this show
while also playing off of
certain pieces of the history and the
lore that we know about
and you know also twisting it around
with this you know this
iteration of their multiverse and
everything that's been going on so yeah
i thought this episode made
for a really intense uh you know
array of character stakes both you know
from the very
uh you know human level to the superman
level
so uh yeah this this was a really really
really quality episode i thought
what did you think sir [ __ ] hated it
yes they
didn't get that f-bomb in it every
minute it was just boring as [ __ ]
i couldn't handle it man yeah it was uh
that was some this is lois's episode
absolutely yeah
yes glad we agree yes and
yeah i think lois um
forgive me for not knowing any of their
names
i don't know who plays anyone in this
show just dawned on me in this moment
i'm like i don't even know how to say
that
superman actor's last name properly so
yeah i don't know anyone's names uh the
actors here
but the performance that given by lois
is so
i'm being very careful with my words
here
uh when it comes to subject broached
here that
i appreciate the show was willing to
dive
into the whole thing about her having a
miscarriage
and uh yes i'm going to be careful that
subject in particular is something that
uh i mean generally is very sensitive
subject
to to broach in in a uh a show or a
movie
and and for uh
the greg alba it's something that
definitely gets
to me uh for whatever variety of reasons
it does
and uh yeah and i think it was done in a
very realistic
manner and the way how she
like it's so easy to be like i gotta go
for the
the tears i gotta go for the drama i
gotta go for
the pain but it really just felt like
this this is a woman having a
conversation right now
and uh the pain that is unfolding but
before her
is is so raw like it it's
she it's such a richly ridden character
a woman or an individual human who is
someone who
is is so gung-ho and is such a hard
worker and it's so much about
moving forward and hitting goals to the
point
where you don't have time to reflect you
don't have time
to grieve you don't have time to to to
process uh your own emotions just like
keep moving on you know it's like i took
my vacation i took my time
i i did my thinking but it's time to
move on it's time to move forward but
there's no real timeline on grief and
it's long-lasting
effects that it has in this episode i i
thought
handled it in a very uh just like the
right
the right pitch because you got to make
it a superhero show still you got to
make it a family drama show still
but it's also a cw show so you got to
know exactly like
how raw you can keep the the handling of
this subject matter while also dealing
with the subject
multiverse and all this [ __ ] and uh i
i thought that what they did with her in
particular from the writing
but mainly her performance uh all the
different variations of how that played
from her
just like lashing out at jonathan
uh was the yes what's on display is rage
but underneath that
is fear and even in the therapy room
you know like it's there's there's this
resistance to feeling that you get from
the performance there like she's
she's so doesn't want to feel
uh what she has to feel and
i love that in the sense of how
human that is and then when it comes
down to
her having the confrontation and the
opening of the the truth box
with jonathan at the end of like i
wasn't
really angry i was terrified you know
like that [ __ ] is that's [ __ ]
heartbreaking
uh yeah you know like and uh
i had to like kind of watch myself
because even right now talking about it
it's making me tear up
uh it's uh yeah like that that [ __ ] uh
it really um is very real and then
you know and then you got like your fun
[ __ ] with multiverses
yeah yeah tonight powers and yeah
fighting along
fighting superman there was an
interesting transitional
um thing that they had going here from
like beginning to end
where all their transitions had this
like they start the sound of
the the next scene um it like overlays
the ending of the scene you're watching
and then you go into it and it's often a
different
mood from the scene you're finishing
yeah i did kind of that throughout the
whole episode and that was the way to
like
transition you through all the different
tones from like sam's musical
performance or talent show
to uh yeah it's like something like kind
of fun and then something that's like
high intensity stakes of what's going on
at the dod and then lois in therapy you
know like they're hopping around between
different
there's all fairly serious stuff for all
these characters but they all have their
own tone to it
you know one's more hiding surreal and
intense action another one's more
dramatic and heft in in that tone so
uh yeah i i do think that
uh this episode was uh it was a powerful
one and um i'm not one to speak on what
makes a powerful woman
uh but i i will say that to me
as someone who's in my life has been
fortunate enough to know
very very strong women um this this
seemed like uh like a very like yeah
that's
i don't know i don't know women like you
man and that is
just plays the stream yeah it's very
real yeah
yeah yeah absolutely and i mean i
thought it was interesting that they
would do
i mean i thought back to something that
you've often touched upon which is just
how like
mel gibson was not in this like the one
thing this show is missing boy
uh no but you know like therapy scenes
can often
be well intentioned but then turn into
delivery systems for character subtext
and i thought that this
uh therapy motif that they kept coming
back to throughout the episode as this
sort of wraparound
was just handled in a really in a way
that felt to me quite natural because it
really felt like a conversation back and
forth between them and like there was
like you said there was this resistance
and uncovering
of emotion you even get the sense that
even though they've only met like a
couple times there's kind of a history
between these characters
and i it's funny and i won't go too
heavily into it because you know i'm not
the person to do that but
um you know as far as real life
circumstances go like this past mother's
day i i saw some things that were
echoing that sentiment of like
you know people uh at least being
pleased
that it is acknowledged the grief and
pain that you know people who have
miscarried go
through and what that means to you know
womanhood motherhood etc and so yeah i
thought that at least
from my you know vaguely aware point of
view they handled that in a really
human in a very poised way in this
episode and it's like you don't have to
do that here
and you know if you do do that in a
setting like this you have to you know
really imbue it with a lot of
credence and a lot of you know again you
know human
uh empathy but yeah just the performance
across the spectrum and then finally
when that comes back to her and jonathan
like the the scene line i thought he did
a
terrific job across the episode too with
just
reacting with these heavy emotions to
these huge bits of information he's
being given
and uh and yeah that scene at the end
between the two of them
where you know she's coming out with it
and they're having their heart to heart
finally like i thought that
that whole arc over the episode was
really beautifully done and i thought
the ways
in which it played into the action were
also pretty conscientious
and two it led to a kind of differently
shaped episode because even though
you know we often joke that jordan
jonathan keeps getting like the shortest
end of the stick in all these scenarios
this really was like kind of uh i don't
know if it's like the the crescendo
yet but it definitely seems like we're
honing further in on him because like
jordan this episode
is mostly things were fine it was like
the first episode where like jordan was
mostly okay for the whole episode
and he even was able to jump up and help
us you know
help with the you know piano and
everything like that
um so yeah like as the shift of the
emotional core happens i thought that
was
yeah just like really nicely handled and
then too all the stuff at the dod i
thought was pretty thrilling and i
appreciated that
again you know i've come to expect this
level of storytelling from the show but
how
you know that stuff they don't skimp
around the information too much you know
after some resistance
john henry irons comes out with his
relation to lois and
you know the whole kind of uh position
he is coming from
and i like that you know clark takes
that in and
you know they they do kind of have to
confront like okay this is a different
world with different circumstances and
they leave this uneasy
sort of truce for the time being but i
thought the way that even they got to
that was pretty well
executed overall and you know again it
had
enough nuance to yeah
just keep being exemplary of what makes
this show work
i feel like that's just this was
is one of the many qualities that keeps
it working yeah i think what they're
doing with the kids
is that they have um
with jordan you're seeing what it's like
to be the son of superman
and then with jonathan you're seeing
what it's like to be the son of lois
lane yeah yeah
there you go and i i love that
apprentice like you you get
both off with both of their characters
you it's both parents with them yes but
i i think like especially that line
um something about extraordinary humans
living with superheroes or something
like that like that's a
really great line and really clicked for
me in that moment of like oh yeah we
don't
maybe jonathan down the road will get
powers maybe he won't but we don't need
him to get powers
and he could still be a very impactful
power like i love jonathan too i think
he's a great character
yeah and uh i don't need him to have
superpowers and
him having to learn how to be great and
strong and live up to the pres like
because
you know like lois lane herself is is is
his icon as well i mean not to the
degree of superman
however she she has become a
well known i mean yes in the comic book
world absolutely but even in the world
that she's got a lot of
show yeah she's a she's a respected
powerful human being
and uh it all just keeps coming back to
to that and um you know like there's all
that stuff there with john henry irons
and
that kind of all played out in a way
that we was you know we
especially once we learned he was steel
it was like okay so he's gonna
eventually become a good guy yeah
yeah yeah and and so like the ending
here isn't surprising but it's well
handled
um and you know like the the i thought i
had a weird
like pull them pull myself out for a
second thought
where you're like oh we're finally
getting in this episode this show like
two kryptonians were able to duke it out
and then they're both inflicted with a
bunch of kryptonite so they can't
really do kryptonian fighting yeah it's
just like two humans struggling to hit
each other
you know both got nerfed yeah it was a
it was a cool fight sequence and they
still haven't managed to ramp the uh
intensity up but i like the
i like how it's be they're really
dealing with superman also having to
have this struggle of being a
an outsider they're bringing him back to
the outsider position or should we or
should we not
trust him you know like it's really if
you're gonna do a superman lois show it
can be very easy to do the route of he's
[ __ ] superman
everyone loves him yeah and then they
don't they're they're challenging that
here like you have john henry irons here
and you got you know
like that line of the uh of
uh what was grandpa's name what's his
name oh
goodness i know the grandmother's name
is natalie yeah
grandpa's name oh okay who's sam sam is
the song
no no no no sam sam lane is is
is is uh the general general yeah
grandpa
yes wade why am i confused why are you
confused yeah the grandparents
yeah grandpa to jonathan and and and
julia is the
yeah okay there's one grandpa in this i
guess i just haven't thought of him in
grandpa
mode yet because he's just always doing
dod
uh yeah sam yeah
wait what's the girl's name the sarah
sarah damn i could probably call her sam
a few times and this is yeah i think
it's a yeah it's an easy mistake to make
yeah it's an easy mistake and then
there's kyle okay yeah all right
yeah so um forgot my original point oh
okay so you have
um sam and
sam his line about uh
i hope for the best but i plan for the
worst even when it comes to you
and this distrust established and you
kind of see that when john henry irons
is talking about
you know you can't trust superman
kryptonians go you even got the other
soldiers who were like
probably yeah it's true you know and
then even
sam is questioning it as well even
though he's the son-in-law and
everything
he's questioning it and uh for the
like i i i find myself in
the position of
as an individual questioning it myself
of if i were in their shoes i'd probably
be questioning superman too
yeah but if they have an emotional
inroad to appeal to him of like oh all
my old friends are back in human bodies
or something this is a conflict
like yeah you can see how superman might
be tempted theoretically toward that
absolutely like i don't know superman
no personally he doesn't confide in me
that's what i mean and if this guy's
coming from an
uh a a an alternate earth that
also plays as a little bit of a
not-too-distant future
in a way uh i could totally see why
people would be like maybe we shouldn't
trust superman because this guy comes
from a planet where they have a superman
looks just like ours
and they're a very similar path you
so i i i i think this show does a good
job
at infusing the questioning and the
accusations
uh very well to the point where even as
a viewer i'm like
yeah you know if people start not
trusting i kind of get it
yeah yeah well yeah and i think they do
nicely to draw that like when sam lays
his position out you're like yeah i mean
that is that literally
is your job and if there is this outside
force who for now is benevolent and a
big help
cool but i mean yeah i guess you would
have to entertain the possibility that
he could go rogue and so yeah it's a
thankless position to be in and i
thought they played that
as well as they could you know yeah yeah
he's not gonna stop developing those
kryptonite weapons
work for kyle oh yeah yeah oh he's going
to do something dumb next episode
he's just going to keep spiraling down
he's going to go climb into the mines
and you know
just cover himself in x-crypt tonight my
prediction is kyle will die in the
season
oh damn getting kyle death vibes
but will a kryptonian come back in his
body
that's second season the cw show yeah
[Music]
season and then bam kind of uh let's go
jump the shark
yeah i i i feel bad for him but this was
also
at least half halfway the most like sort
of just kyle character episode we've had
so far
first half anyway yeah i feel like he's
gonna
he's gonna yeah he's because he what was
he doing at the end was he like
packing a bunch of drinks i got the
sense that he was
yeah like hiding his his like liquor bag
off the counter or something like that
it's that kind of stuff i wish they
would go i wish i could push the
envelope a little bit more on
that cool yeah especially because like
that's i want to see a very domestically
violent kyle
well honestly but he always falls into
the meme trap though of like oh just
when you think it's getting interesting
with kyle uh here comes the uh he's
jealous about morgan edge again damn it
yeah uh
it just seems like it's headed down some
path matt thought it was like oh kyle's
gonna go behind uh lana's back
at one point but then he did it he just
got drunk and missed this kid's
recital and superman little super boy
remembered how to
play piano poorly for her yeah
i was like i was like what i liked that
that it wasn't like perfect it was but
at the same time i was like
if you haven't played in a while like
are you going to be able to pick this up
at all
maybe he's a half prodigy he's got
super uh piano ability was kryptonite
kryptonite i wonder what's going to
become of the
like the sarah stuff i i really
that's probably the thing i least cared
about is how i would put it
uh it's not bad
uh and it's shot so well and i and i
like the talent show scene
a lot and they're good to like the like
the acting is good yeah and i love i
love the moment when when they're up
there and then jordan
she looks she's that says this very
specific line and it looks like there's
a jordan
you're like yeah you too look at you
cuties go that's adorable
you scamps i really uh i enjoy that
moment uh
but i didn't quite i i guess i got to
see what's integral about it
it didn't feel uh super duper important
yeah i felt sort of like okay we need to
have jonathan and sarah in here are
jordan and sarah in here somewhere and
and we also probably need a little
levity
or a little something that's not going
to be so emotionally rending for this
episode
however it does sort of yeah it is sort
of the odd plotline
out i guess in that sense because it's
also not so substantial that it leaves
the marks beyond
the recital scene and and perhaps i mean
when she
uh talks to kyle at the very end i
thought that was a good scene
but but yeah it kind of once you cut
back to like
you know things going on at the dod
you're like oh yeah there are way huger
stakes going on
uh although i do think it's meant to
serve as a
as a as a because the theme of this
seemed to deal a lot with
uh
the regrets of not facing your fears
this is what it
a lot of this seemed to be focused on
especially with lois and
that's what was going on with sam
because you have that's what
lois is talking about in therapy then
you go to the scene with sam and
kyle no sarah dammit
sarah and kyle yeah uh yeah you go to
the scene with sarah and kyle
and uh
it's he's the one talking about how
there's a little quote i i used to hear
a lot from a personal development
speaker named jim rohn
and it was about how uh uh
the pain of discipline weighs
ounces and the pain of regret weighs
pounds is that right
wait which one's heavier
i questioned myself there is it pounds
or did he go
bigger like tons or some
you know it's the point either way
leadership weighs less yeah yeah the
sacrifice relates
the willingness to give a chance uh like
the pain of regret will weigh on you
longer
and it's interesting how him not going
to the recital which is the and
the reason not the recital but the
audition and that's the reason why
the reason she went to the audition was
because of what he talked about
and yet he's the one who lands in a
regretful position
yeah uh towards her so
i know there's kind of a bit of there's
a bit of poetry in there
yeah rhymes yeah couplets rhyming
it's a bar it's a cinematic bar
anyway we've talked about this episode
long enough yes
it's good tell us all the easter eggs
you caught
anyway guys uh thanks for being here
check us out on patreon thanks to
prathan for adding this subscribe click
that notification bell
hit like buttons and uh last month lisa
michael b michael i've had several phone
conversations with you in the last
couple weeks
you're an incredible gentleman and more
people should be watching your superman
on lois reactions
guys he does an insanely great job
i'm threatened by how good his reactions
are
so much so that i want to promote him
and i want him to do well because he
deserves it
because he works his butt off he's
helped us out plenty he's been a long
time supporter of our patreon page he's
become a really good friend of mine
especially
however i think what needs to be done is
he needs to get more views on the
superman and lois videos
but they shouldn't cross our view count
that's what matters i want to just be
right behind a thousand behind
just at least one thousand behind i want
to know we're doing better than him
still
but still get him up there just just
keep an eye on our video
him up yeah but don't let him
so uh there's a way we can all
coordinate this together for the few who
have stayed here
till the end yeah uh just now there's a
way to do it you know you want to uplift
people
but you know within reason there's
he's white does he really need sleaze
lifted far enough
enjoy your privilege michael b
seriously mike you rock man thank you
for the help especially last week thank
you for all the help you did